[Music]
i will eat
chinese food anywhere if i see it in a
strip mall i'll get a hankering for it i
once
shot a movie out in the desert it was a
tiny little town called trona california
truly the middle of the desert and on
the way to get to this location
you would pass a certain you know a few
like dusty little gas stations and
there's a little turn off in the middle
of nowhere an all-you-can-eat chinese
buffet
with like a hand-painted sign and of
course i stopped there and ate there and
um of course that night i got violently
ill about a week later i went back to
los angeles and i stopped there again
and i hit there again i ate there twice
and i got sick twice i got sick again
and my thought process was well surely i
can't i'm not gonna get sick again that
was an anomaly that was and the food was
good enough and it was like actually not
packed you know for the amount of times
you've eaten disgusting chinese food in
your life it's a miracle that you look
the way you do that's a miracle
that's you mean i should look handsome
and fit oh that's so nice life could be
a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your handsome ha ha you said it host
justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
with me as always is
i think you're handsome come on well
sometimes you're not
what yes
[ __ ] you sometimes you're by your own
you you know you know
we have facebook i just don't want you
to say it right i can say it about
myself well what would you say about
your face right now yeah it looks pretty
good right
it's just like a summer bronzed
a little unshaven
yeah but we also have very like
malleable faces we have like a lot of we
christian i used to do this thing where
um
i don't know if anyone can relate to
this but you'd shake your head like
you'd like shake your you let your face
go loose and then take a picture of it
yeah sometimes it would look like
because my face is so malleable so
malleable it's hard to tell just by
looking at me normally it is but it is
extremely malleable and by the way i
don't recommend this face shaking no we
stopped doing it because i think we were
giving ourselves a little concussions
doing it but my picture would often be
like a cartoon like my mouth would be
on the right side of the frame
and the rest of my face would be totally
on that it was like it was like cartoon
it was like goofy yeah you know when
like dogs and cartoons see like
something they're attracted it's like oh
god and their eyes like pop out i have
some crazy pictures of me doing that
your mouth was cartoonishly exaggerated
yeah anyway uh speaking of you can't do
that anymore with uh self with uh camera
phones with iphones i don't think it
doesn't capture that i don't know
actually i haven't tried
ourselves a concussion yeah i think it
made us dumber i mean i i think i've
lost
dad we did give ourselves something
because you have to because your brain
is knocking into your stomach that's one
of my biggest regrets but you know i was
really good at it i still regret it
so
when you were making that bad decision
to uh eat chinese food twice that made
you sick you were
working on a movie called who's called
one who's called water well it's called
just dead water water okay dumb title
but they're both um it was called one
part sugar but there was an actor in
that movie uh a castleman of yours who
uh
never really amounted to much
but he's he's a nice person so we
thought we'd have him on the show today
yeah uh his name's jonah hill jonah hill
um
and yeah jonah was in we did a couple
movies together
but like back to back we just couldn't
get enough of because we were also
living together at the time it was fun
to like commute to work together
um but we did this this little move and
jonah was the one that totally and
rightfully so shamed me for eating that
chinese food twice so funny and i was
like you know it made me sick again he
was like what did you the [ __ ] you think
was gonna happen i remember him like so
incredulous
are you kidding um and he's right i mean
he was like yeah he was right he was so
funny and honest and um when you guys
lived together in santa monica i lived
upstairs from you guys and um and we all
hung out a bunch and
you know
right when i met him i knew there's
something
about him you know people say you use
the term it factor and it's really hard
to define and there's something
uh but with him
i felt that with him totally i mean i
never would have known he'd be like you
know starring opposite leonardo dicaprio
i mean i never thought like that but
yeah uh there was something about him
that was kind of captivating yes
captivating that's true he he would like
you talk about this in the in the
interview a little bit but
we would all go out and it would be a
table it would be like a power play
player's table of people would be like
vince vaughn and sam rocco and these
these like cool older people and i
remember jonah was this like young guy
that like hadn't really done anything
yet and he would like hold court
and be like the star and make everyone
laugh and tell these funny stories
and i remember thinking oh there's
something really special about this guy
yeah he would really turn it on but it
wasn't like didn't feel performancy or
he was trying to show off you know
something so natural about you
he had a new factor he just had it he
glowed he like people wanted to be
around him and and i was i was proud
that he was like my friend so i'd like
he's like showing off your you know i
was like show him off uh and i remember
afterwards everyone had the same
reaction who is that you know people
gravitated toward that it was so
captivating is a really good word for
what he had
um he would probably make fun of me for
saying that he's captivating totally oh
my god i would i would love to get the
audio of him listening to this uh
so you did i wasn't there you did the
interview in at his house yeah at his
house which he immediately felt sheepish
about because um it was a house that he
in in bel air it was like a very
large like palatial kind of and he's
going to be pissed i mean for saying
this but i will say he's it's only
temporary and he goes the first thing he
said he's like he's like sharon picked
it out his mom's name is sharon who we
should also have on the show because
she's such a character and a really
sweet person but like
she's a real character if you know in
fact he there's a version of her in the
movie uh 21 jump straight which jonah i
think wrote
yeah and um i forget the actress really
good actress plays a version of sharon
feldstein in that movie and
his dinette so if you've seen that
you'll know kind of who sharon is and
jonah and the actress they have that
similar dynamic which jonah had with his
mom
when i'd go over their house he'd be
like mom he'd like
he kind of like yell at her and like mom
we're the snacks you know really he was
like a kid and and uh
oh stop yeah shut you shut up and they
kind of like give each other [ __ ] but in
a like affectionate way i never
really seen that uh yeah it was really
fun
to be around i remember he would he's
probably not gonna love this either but
uh
he when he lived in that little tiny
room that he calls the pantry he listens
we now know he listens i know uh he used
to
he lived direct like if you opened his
bedroom door on one side like he had two
doors and better one open to the kitchen
and one open to
the laundry area and so his room is like
a tiny little pantry and so he literally
had a door that opened up to the laundry
machine he was like six feet from the
laundry machine
and he used to load his laundry into a
big bag every week
get in his car
and drive it
home
his mom did the laundry it's chevy hills
across town yeah it was kind of a far
drive it wasn't like
if you guys
don't
know him he uh he you do know him so i'm
not even gonna say what he's been in
because you know him and he's been in
tons of just had water
strange wilderness he's been in tons of
huge movies and um he's been nominated
for two oscars and now he's uh an
accomplished director he directed a
movie that you guys should all see
called mid 90s he wrote directed and uh
it's a coming-of-age story about this
group of skateboarders in l.a and it's
really great he i think is going to go
on to make more great uh movies he's
going to go on to direct yeah for sure
um but you guys should all check that
out and uh you should all stay tuned for
justin's
uh chat with his old friend my old
roommate bill rumi jonah hill life could
be a dream sweetheart
hello hello
my dad has literally never liked norse i
think he's seen one to two films i've
been in what really
he likes um moneyball
and that's pretty much that's pretty
much it yeah because it has to do with
math
wait that's strange because book smart
by the way that was my favorite movie he
goes oh my god have you seen book smart
and i was like yeah dad and he's like oh
it's
such a charmer well maybe because sharon
is so the opposite of sharon's like
i don't think sharon's ever been able to
watch a movie i've been in she's just so
excited i'm in a movie that she can tell
her friends that she just i don't think
she's ever like digested any of the
materials oh so she doesn't like she
doesn't like talk to you about it about
like onesie
no she there's one movie that i know she
was affected by and she talked about it
a lot which was cyrus
but other than that i think she's just
waiting to like get on social media to
be like my son's in a movie but now my
sister's like very quickly becoming more
yes than me pretty amazing like this
week or past couple weeks especially
i'm like watching beanie my sister
she was blowing up already and then she
was in book smart and it was like okay
this is like
a star making kind of performance right
and like weirdly similar to super super
bad which was also dope because she you
know her well and especially when she
was young yeah it's so weird to i'm
proud of her and she's great in the
movie she's so good but it's still i
can't imagine how you feel because it's
weird for me yeah to see her success
because i yeah so clearly we went to her
i
bar
i i still think about that for my
friends i'm like
maybe they're used to it with me i don't
know and maybe it seems less weird but
for me it's very surreal well i also met
you in the capacity if you were an actor
when i met you i mean like you were on
that path i met beenie when she was like
a kid who was like had like broadcasting
i had just gotten on that path that's
true and she had wanted to be
an actress and she was like one year she
was like a real like broadway she's like
she's literally a runway baby yeah she's
broadway beanie feline dude that's her
name she came out of sharon she was like
with placenta on her was like hello my
baby hello mom yeah she was like the wb
frog but but a little baby yeah i'm so
proud of her
obviously you know how dope she is as a
person
but the things that like made me
like she doesn't have the insecurities i
had and those kind of things that like
maybe made success not as awesome for my
personality
and then so she's like a already a
formed person
and a great formed person but then i'm
watching her go from like kind of like i
think book smart was so dope because
everyone was like oh it's a female super
bad like instead of running away from
that she like was so confident she's
like i'm a [ __ ] run right into that
yeah because she loves acting she really
just loves what it is he is like a
[ __ ] like
gnarly died in the wool actress yeah
like an actor you know you're just like
you mentioned sam rockwell you ran into
him this morning yeah which is your i
met sam through you originally yeah and
i've worked with sam
and then i feel that way about sam don't
you that he is like yes i can't imagine
him doing anything sam is like an actor
with a capital a yeah i'm like a movie
nerd with a soft a and a soft like w and
a maybe a hard d they are you know
part w
whatever yeah
um but like oh you would say that that
like the d the d is the heart that's
what you i seriously think the last
thing i did
was maniac maybe or um
uh so that was like two years like i
haven't acted straight up in like two
years no and and do you feel like this
do you are you climbing the wall wow i
was in therapy and my therapist asked me
i was like book smart beanie's blowing
up but it's still like kind of like a
teen movie kind of thing
um
you know
and then she got cast as monica owinski
like a week ago okay so ryan murphy's
doing one of those american stories or
whatever
and she's monica lewinsky and tell me
you're not playing bill clinton
it's so nice
there's just too much there of like like
that's crazy but like like you know we
have the same agent and agent was
telling me she was went to harry potter
world with beanie in london and then
no one knew it was getting announced
like i didn't know about it she's like i
have a secret but i can't tell you about
it weird but i read it on the news weird
so i read it on the news and then my my
agent told me they went back it got
announced while they were at harry
potter world and when they left the
hotel there was no photographers and
stuff and when they got back to the
hotel they were like congrats on monica
lewinsky like
like blah blah god so that's going to be
a whole other i think it's a next kind
of like progression in that thing of
like iconic character for like an like
amazing director
not that i mean
like you know they all
like all these things but they're kind
of like but similar to your
progression like you you know i mean if
anyone knows like you know what those
steps are i mean yeah and when it's
gonna change a little bit right and so
what he said to me is like how do you
feel do you feel like weird like he
asked if i felt weird that's a valid
question and it was cool i was glad he
asked me because i was like you know how
i know i'm healthy for the first time in
my life
is like
i'm just stoked
but i also am grateful not to be in that
rat race right like she's in that round
she's entering she's in the rat race
whether she wants to be or not meaning
she's on the wave of like things blowing
up and blowing up and blowing up and i
am honestly on like yeah kind of like
the mellow part of the wave where you're
like riding in the shore and you're like
that was cool but it was also scary as
[ __ ] and also exhausting and like
like if i don't get cool acting parts
again forever and i just direct
commercials or i just drink music videos
i'm like as long as i can like have a
family and do stuff like that i don't
you don't acquire personal you don't
acquire value from from those things the
way you do the thing that made my life
good
was i don't identify with my job anymore
i feel that totally that's awesome you
know my life really changed when i
stopped identifying myself as an actor
like that became my that was always my
thing like i'm i'm not i'm an actor i it
was part of my you know i think for
anyone listening who has like
aspirations or isn't i think that's the
most valuable thing uh to impart i think
it's like
be a good person
and if you're talented it'll work out
and if you find out you're not that
talented right then you'll know there's
something else out there you know it's
like it's like i was like get successful
and then shit'll fall into place and
then i had to start to work at like 30
as opposed to like 15 or something you
know beanie is now cresting like in a
way that you was that super bad for you
or was it even after that super bad had
the effect because it was just this
timing thing of like it was a runaway
like it was immediately a smash hit
whereas book smart
comedy is just in a weird place like
theatrically and so on and so forth
there's a lot more like
intellectualizing that could go into it
but because it wasn't like a runaway
smash hit it was like a critical beloved
like everyone who saw it loved it yeah
it was more like she kind of got the
illest version which was like was like
you can star in movies now everyone in
the world thinks you're a dope actress
but you're not like famous in belgium
maybe like right now you know
you can't go to belgium anymore and for
me it was like as you know you know
you're around like it just it definitely
was an overnight thing i remember that i
mean that was even before the movie came
out because there were billboards
everywhere yeah it was i mean it was
comically exaggerated yeah you know like
that's the only way i could put it is
like
and and michael you know
uh even
cooler like kind of realized in that
moment at 19 he kind of stepped back a
little bit because he was like
i'm not feeling good in this thing i
don't speak for him too much but he's a
close friend still and like you know i
always respected that at 19 he could see
what it felt like and go like i'm
listening to my feelings and i'm not i'm
gonna do my own it's pretty ballsy but i
didn't have that and what what was your
thing at the time were you like i just
want to keep staying on this train i
want to keep i was like dude
i was just so
in my head like
this is what you wanted
this is sick
you're in a movie that you actually like
yeah
you're you're um but was it not making
it was it because
people a lot of people i talked to about
this kind of thing they've said a
version of this where it was a shock and
was it was depressing when it didn't
they didn't find happiness in in that
like it wasn't enough i don't think i
was clear-headed enough to like even
know what happiness was so i think it
was cool in my
like weird mind at the time yeah i was
like
dude i'm like cool
i was like girls like me and like that's
crazy and like yeah as you know i was
like you know a dorky guy that wasn't
you know well everyone always like i
mean that's the thing about you i
remember meeting you and i was so kind
of like proud to have discovered you as
a friend if that makes any sense like i
remember
because socially you would go to these i
wouldn't you meant rockwell when you met
anyone
you would like hold court and you were
just the best to be around you know like
[ __ ] hilarious and i i knew everyone
who met you knew you were
it was special but i
so i
hated the thought of that you're like
little secrets like everybody's yeah
yeah now everyone knows my secret garden
what's that movie is it a secret garden
uh yeah that everyone now can like
prune your hedges
yeah i was like oh [ __ ] i but i it was
my point is like this was never a
surprise i was never like i can't
believe this had you know um
it but but superbad was so monumental
that like the overnight element of it
was was i guess a surprise and i can't
imagine how you must have felt but you
also
did not take the easy path in terms of
like movie stardom i remember
some of those like i remember like
transformers when they offered you that
i was like why
would you not do that you're thinking
jonah got off her transformers too
that's no maybe you don't like if you're
like us you don't see your positive
things as much you know what i mean like
or
i've been so unhumble in my life i try
and like practice humility at all cost
because
i guess i was able to not do like
certain things like i did cyrus instead
of the hangover right right like that
was one where i remember like people in
my life were like
literally like what the [ __ ] yeah you
know
what the [ __ ] like
because the script was so dope because i
was like dude i was like i can't believe
i can be in this movie yeah i guess like
maybe um you know i i come from a
fortunate background
um i didn't mind being broke i lived in
your like pantry and i had a lot of fun
like you know like like i never took i
never took like you know my dad's a a
successful account my mom's successful
i didn't i never front yet great people
and i i had a really like
you know yeah i wasn't like a brilliant
i wasn't billionaire but i was like
never struggled for money growing yeah
your parents were very good parents i
mean they were like yeah i always loved
going over your house like yeah they
were just very warm welcoming people um
and they're amazing and they more put
like my dad was like if you
he's like first of all we're not the
kind of like we don't have the kind of
money where you're getting any money
that was like what he said to me when i
was young he's like i know we like live
in a house and like you've never had to
like never clearly never missed a meal
but like like you know you
he's like but you don't have anything
coming to you oh interesting so
you know so make your own way make your
own way and he's like i don't care if
you're like rich i don't care if you're
whatever if you want to play the violin
but like
be the best kind of like be the best
violin player and be like the best
prostitute the best
and you know what i wasn't as good as i
had to realize i wasn't that talented
you have to give up that dream yeah wait
but when you're a kid did you want to do
that i i don't think i ever knew this no
i wanted to write for the simpsons
that's right that was like all i ever
wanted right so i was like that was my
life's like goal from eight years old
what was it like then being on the
simpsons it was awesome man yeah it was
awesome everything got so surreal not
bad so it wasn't like measured yeah it
was like it was like when we were living
together the year before yeah i'd be
like oh my god if i could meet like
ian maxtone graham who's like a sims
famous simpsons writer i'd like die
to like nine months later
like
anyone you've ever
thought of or something like knows who
you are and you get to meet them and
stuff so
it it uh it is a wild truly wild
experience i don't even know if it
really happens anymore in the same way i
don't like maybe if you're like
spider-man or something maybe like tom
holland or something like
like especially because movies i mean
it's a whole other subject yeah but like
there's so much [ __ ] out there yeah it
was like a thing maybe euphoria is like
that now but i don't even know like i'm
just too out of touch yeah
i was this end of my time
i've often said that everyone when she
came out i i was like yo this is this
looks familiar
well i saw those billboards with her
crying i thought at first it was you and
then i noticed it didn't have a beard
he's really going for something yeah
he's such a chameleon
um how did how uh what was your role
with uh this is something else as well
as i know you i never really knew this
what was your role with beanie and
jordan growing up like how did you fit
in
with with
like two childhoods um
uh i was the younger brother i should
say my brother is gone now which is very
sad but um i was the younger brother
to my older brother who was six years
older than me
and that was a challenging thing but
like it's fine we were just like older
brother younger brother you know you
know i'm i that's i'm sorry i shouldn't
i feel like i shouldn't have brought you
it's life i the idea for me is like you
should be able to talk about things you
know
i miss him a lot but he's a very unique
guy that he wasn't as open of a human
being
and did you know that when you were kids
was did you get a sense of that i was
just too young i kind of worked through
all this [ __ ] when i got older yeah yeah
but then so then he went to college and
then i was like or he was like there was
only a couple years that overlapped with
like him and beanie there because he was
five he was 16 when beanie was born oh
wow and i was almost 10. oh my god so
when beanie came along
a i was like i'm gonna be the dopest
older brother that's one thing that's
important to me one of the few decisions
i made in youth that was sound or good
and i was like i'm going to be the best
older brother to this person
but also she was like a doll yeah you
know it was it was no threat there was
no like yeah if she was a boy a year
younger than me
i might my insecurities might have raged
over but it was like what are you gonna
be mean to this like cute little
basketball that's like wearing a dress
she's like heaven on earth and beanie
was always the best so it was like
i don't know she's my like my hero my
best friend i just like i look up to her
a lot i'm 35 now and i've i've always
tried to like i like to know what music
is what's up i asked beanie like what's
the woke [ __ ] think
beanie teaches with elegance which i
think is important like she'll correct
people
but she doesn't make them feel like
jerks or they're evil there's no
judgment in you
if a family member says something like
accidentally offensive or something you
know she's like yo you shouldn't say
that because of x y and z and you don't
feel attacked and i think people need to
like teach each other without like
because then what happens if someone
comes at you that hard you're like [ __ ]
you i'm going to stay i'm going to stay
in my box with my little group of people
and then you don't see the world and you
don't feel the world like that's
released these echo chambers and this
sense of tribalism that yeah i mean
you must have felt like that you've done
things and you've said things you've
gotten trouble god i've gotten in so
much trouble so what's that like how do
you contend with the
with that like uh hostile internet one
of my things for me is i don't
participate it doesn't exist to me like
like
mid 90s was the real thing that got me
off the internet because of the critics
it was such a
personal movie yeah yeah that whole
experience changed my life for the
better yeah i was just turned up like i
just was returned i was turned to like i
was four years into a movie i was like
it couldn't be more like emotional or i
couldn't have given more of myself to it
than it was like we were 100 on rotten
tomatoes
then we were like dipped down to like 98
on ryan you're like 98 is amazing but
like who what's the two percent from
right no but not even that it was like i
was at 98 i remember i was on my way to
the premiere at the courthouse where i
grew up skating crazy as they were they
were playing it on a blow-up screen
figure skating
yeah for those who haven't seen mid 90s
it's the kristy yamaguchi story and i
was her trainer for many years um
it's like a heartwarming item almost
like the most emotional thing that could
happen which is like all my friends from
growing up came that skated there sharon
wasn't there yes
yeah she was she was busy or something
um
and the rotten tomatoes score which i'm
clearly live checking like clearing like
uh whatever pressing enter so it appears
again
like a mental patient yeah like like
it drops
from
uh like 98 to 81 i of course i know the
exact numbers which is where it ended up
right like eighty-one
weird
i've had like actual meltdowns but like
i almost went into shock wow like
watching the number drop it was what got
me off the internet entirely because i
was like my whole the movie didn't
matter my friends i made during the
movie didn't matter the emotions i
experienced in the movie didn't matter
yeah the learning as a filmmaker didn't
matter
your vision gets clouded with yourself
yeah
and then that's the kind of thing where
you're like get out of self obviously
it's like get help someone be present be
like you know
don't make it up about you
well i'm grateful i have that chance in
my life like multiple times of just
[ __ ] up and having the chance to get
better as a person i can see it i mean
i've seen you i've seen you go through
it and and we've been through things
together and we've you know but i think
a big part of that that success which i
think is the ultimate success is um
you have a good family i mean you have
somebody like beanie and you have
friends from
high school still i mean you're still
friends with those guys i i think
unfortunately yes oh okay sorry
i was at a bachelor party this weekend
in utah
paul downes was paul downs there yes he
was no i just saw him last night i think
i've mentioned him on everything it was
my friend from
preschool no kidding and he was the only
one that was like not from our preschool
or high school on oh weird wait you
still have a friend from preschool yeah
like multi like 10 of them were on this
trip
weird and we put on diapers and play
with blocks now it's kicking the old
days
we lived the glory
and everyone sat on and gave a speech
about this dude matt dines you've met
with me before he's a great guy and matt
dines shout out maddie matty deep
everyone gave this speech about him
and everything they said about him was
based around the idea that he has always
done the right thing and always been a
great friend and great
person and my speech was like
dude
i
am so grateful
that you gave me the opportunity and
i'll say the same thing to you i'm very
grateful that you gave me the
opportunity justin
to
give me opportunities even though i
haven't always been the most present or
good friend and i think
that is like what shows a great person
meaning you him various people in my
life
live life i'll say lives because i've
lived many lives but like
you know there are people that do the
right thing and then there are people
that do the right thing
and allow for those who don't always
aren't always there yet to
[Music]
get better what that means it means a
lot because that's now what i value the
most you mentioned the kids that you
grew up with these preschool kids at
this um sorry i want to clarify i was in
utah at a bachelor party and the rest of
the kids were pre rest people were
preschoolers that were there okay all
right all right i was the only adult i
think i totally [ __ ] up that sentence
and then park city of all places to hang
out with preschoolers it was so dude
all i wanted to do was go to the f the
fundamentalist mormon parts but it was
like two hours away because i watch all
these documentaries on yeah f d f d l l
latter day you got to say the f because
the f is the fundamentalist oh
those those are the ones like warren
jeff's was a fun oh like under the
banner of heaven vibes and mult and and
uh yeah right jeff's born jason's my
favorite he's the ghost we gotta have
yeah
do you know why
i i dude watch it there's a documentary
showtime about warren jeff's that is
like
so [ __ ] gnarly and his voice alone
just sends shivers
he's in the documentary and he when he
gets to jail
he like is on the phone with one of
those phones with his his boy like one
of his disciples
i am a fraud i am not a prophet i have
like made all this up i am like a piece
of [ __ ] but he doesn't curse but like
i'm i'm i'm a false prophet blah blah
and the dude who hears it is like
he's been possessed
he's been possessed like he doesn't
believe this and then like he gets out
of his guilt spiral like a week later
and he's like yes i was possessed by a
spirit i am the prophet
let go
let's go
classic jeffs classic jeff's bait and
switch dude
the [ __ ] devil spirit bait and switch
[ __ ]
possess fake possession for a week yeah
i'm going to start using that oh wait
i'm whenever i [ __ ] up with friends i'll
be like i think i know yeah
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vied for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again
yeah so after super bad came out i was
like super bugged out by how like
like larger talk to kevin about that
about i remember when kevin didn't kevin
tell you tell us when we hung out with
when we went to that day
dude i didn't go because i hate dave
matthews but i hung out with you guys
before before yeah
i don't hate dave ryan he's the person i
know it's okay i just am like
aggressively not a fan of that band but
like so i was like there's no way i'm
spending three hours in my life doing
this but we were with the homie oliver
platt too yeah he was the god he was one
of the coolest dudes i've ever met kevin
bacon said one of the funniest things
during the group
on your show oh no no yeah but the story
but like did i tell you what what he
said to togo no during the dave matthews
concert which i was enjoying i was like
i didn't realize i like take matthews as
much as i do but
i knew you would have liked it yeah yeah
all the all the starting stuff up your
alley
all the songs sound vaguely the same
it's like dude
they're all kind of like halfway through
the concert and they're all these like
middle-aged white people dancing around
uh kevin bacon leaned over to togo and
he just goes
get down white people
and togo said it's one of the hardest
he's ever watched that's how i feel
about dave matthews man it was like i
had this carpool driver and she had two
cds jay-z hard knock life and dave
matthews band whatever [ __ ] album's
called and every day i got one or the
other and on like one day i got to
choose obviously chose jay-z
and then the other day i had to listen
to like squish
like a tuba and a saxophone on the way
to like seventh grade and i was just
like
it made me uh hate it so like
sarah schecker my old carpool driver i'm
michelle sarah
schechter no you don't know oh oh wait i
wonder where she is now i know us wait a
minute sir dude everyone's name's sarah
that's jewish
like there's no like
um there's yeah i know like 41 sarah
checkers and literally that might not
even be your name
okay all right but i gotta say like one
of the things you did bring me around a
lot like yeah like so generous with like
dude my friend's awesome oh my god
well it was really appreciated wow well
you also made things
so far i mean like we had you know we
had a lot of fun it was a great time i i
know it's funny to talk about like you
know how we've grown and it's not it's
good it's it's noticeable but like on a
if i were to go through that kind of
confused and secure period with anyone
i'm glad i went through it with you
because we
it was just [ __ ] fun it was just we
had a lot of fun i know there's things i
want to talk about like jim right like
the guy that we live oh my god i just
think about so justin i'll just say in
one of his generous everyone who knows
him knows he's such a generous dude i
had no money no success
no anything we met on a show called
campus ladies that you were
right yeah that was my first uh you were
a regular
i think i was a regular or maybe like
guest they had me like holding on on get
multiple guest stars we hit it off
immediately it was an all-improv show
and i was like yeah actually i got to
give a shout out to campus ladies
because i was like you're my first job
cheryl hines produced it but you it was
a cool break in that like i did a scene
with you i did a scene with maya rudolph
i did a scene with like mad people that
i like thought were dope and like i was
like 19 or something yeah it's i
i just remember being
again like struck by your most
improv actors that age and i still i see
it all the time though you see it they
go looking
for jokes you know like vince would
always say like you can't go looking for
the funny you gotta just stay you know
oh dude we gotta talk about this oh god
oh that's right oh god dude oh man all
right justin introduced me to vince
vaughn initially
in his like generous well let me finish
my generation
dude i lived at my parents house
i was miserable i was 18. i just gotten
dumped from my first like real
relationship you used to say you had you
used to reference them as your roommates
yeah you're like i have a 55 year old
roommate and a
male room and a 54 year old female
roommate which is a joke i probably
lifted from like a harold rammus movie
or something like i lived at home
you know that show had ended or
something you know and it wasn't enough
to pay rent
justin let me live in his house well
that's the nice version it was a pantry
i always say i live in a pantry like in
a fairy tale no one ever believes me but
full-on pantry yeah was it converted i
mean it was they called it a bedroom uh
and i think we called it well we didn't
we called it a pantry it was but the
laundry room was in my room for the
whole house which the house was like
four units so it was like people i
didn't know doing laundry while i was in
my bed my
my boudoir
yeah and it was right off the kitchen
because that's where pantries are yeah
it was i was i was kitchen adjacent in
the laundry room internal
so like i i
and we lived without a dog named moose
who was really um
hyper sexual yeah
yeah living in that house i didn't i
don't know if i knew that it was your i
guess i must have that was your first
time
well i've gone to college briefly i
think i was yes i was either 18 or 19 i
was very young you had gone to new
school you went to college in new york i
went to boulder for one semester
got kicked out my mom calls me a forty
thousand dollar sweatshirt
you know her best line my mom's best
line is she's like someone would be like
wow you've been married to rich for like
40 years and she goes yeah i've been
married 40 years but it's not serious
i think that's the illest line about
marriage like ever she's like yeah i've
been married 40 years but it's not
serious my mom's funny
how did you get kicked out of boulder
again i got 0.0
oh you said that like somebody who uh
got kicked out of i get a zero point no
because it's a line from animal house
they're like they get to they get to uh
john belushi and they're like lukowski
or whatever his name is they're like
zero
point zero
wait but you you just didn't do well i
didn't go everywhere
[Laughter]
what were you smoking my parents i
begged my parents not to go to college i
was like please don't let me go to
college because
you wanted to go right into like try to
i was like how do i become a writer yeah
i was like that's all i want to do like
please help me
like just i don't care i'll get a job
and you want to i never took a dollar
from my parents ever i can attest to
that that's why you're living in the
pantry yeah i was living in a pantry
just in case anyone thought i was like
made in the shade that is not untrue um
and then and then um
but you guys dad met with my college
counselor without me
and she got the deal on like where i
would get in and he said hot or cold
and i said well i've never been in snow
before so cold and those i got into
arizona and boulder so those were my
choices okay let's see having never gone
there and visiting or anything are you
serious they left me there and i was
like all right this is weird like i
don't relate to like anybody here
were you like happy guys
i played a lot of bocce ball smoked a
lot of weed uh-huh well drank a lot of
um
uh
what was it called it was like a
hillbilly
or something no it was like um
jim beam and gatorade or something like
that it was nasty as [ __ ] you know like
um so were you just so but it was was it
fun did you
or was it just like yeah there were some
fights but i wasn't like i was just such
a waste of life yeah
so so but anyway i bounced by force
i was forcibly asked to be removed
and then my dad was like dude you gotta
go to college like you can't just like
not go rich is an accountant i mean he's
very he's a very bright guy he
he's also the first person that that uh
told me what your last name was yeah
when joan and i were doing accepted for
i think a month and a half you wouldn't
tell me
you i was like
you wouldn't tell me well dude it's
[ __ ] that's a crazy thing even
because i was 18 years old my name is
jonah hill feldstein that's like my like
birth name or whatever
um i was in the sag office when i was 18
and i just like made that decision yeah
that was it like like that decision in
that chair when i was 18. and then when
my sister kept her last name i was like
that's so sick
like but i was 18 now i'm 35. which you
have to oh so you think now if you had
done it you would have yeah it's weird
now if i like change my name or
something but like but like what did
your 18 year old shouldn't just like be
allowed to like that's a weird thing for
an eighteen-year-old to decide and then
yeah you're so unformed at that point
what what i was just like that's a cool
sounding name or like i don't know i
mean it's like easier to it's also
it's yeah also back then like you know
you didn't want to you don't want to be
a jew in hollywood
it's all changed dude but like i
honestly like one of the things i i love
about directing and writing and stuff
but like with acting like
like i had to fight really hard not to
be typecast yeah so that's
i'm
my name is jonah i'm jewish
hello jonah i was like you know such a
supporter severely overweight
funny guy something i'm able to talk
about now
is i wasn't even able to like mention
weight because i was so insecure about
it
but now as an adult i'm like that's
crazy that i let people
let you know if you read interviews with
me and [ __ ] or you read how people
review me or they
talk about me
like it did major psychological damage
to me and if you read that now those
writers would be like oh yeah you can't
like body shame someone like that bob
yeah you're funny just deal with it dude
like that's your [ __ ] you know and
you're like
wait why am i like fully
[ __ ] up
yeah it's yeah it's really it was crazy
so i just was like yo i'm not gonna do
that and i'm not gonna
and i'm not gonna be typecast and then i
got labeled as like over serious uh that
was then my the next knock on me was
like this dude takes himself so
seriously
everybody else is so easy going and fun
like you take yourself seriously it's
like
well i don't know maybe i do yeah maybe
i am a serious person you know yeah well
i'm an adult and i'm like yeah you know
what i wish i was like as strong as my
sister or michael or people that were
like
like
a don't [ __ ] like like in a kind way
like don't be like that towards me and
be
just like
you know i don't know just we're
stronger in some ways well you are much
more that's why it must have been you
you mentioned this and you started to
talk about it how your persona your
on-screen person because you had done
all those comedies didn't especially
from superbad didn't necessarily
match up to certainly who you were
becoming the way i came to a conclusion
was that's not me yeah literally
c is not me what they're talking to is
not me
what so does that affect the way you
behave around them are you then able is
it easier to say yeah it's easier to be
a cool mellow person
yeah i also got healthier and happier as
a person which made me like if i do feel
uncomfortable be like hey i'm really
tired like thank you very much yeah i'm
really polite really respectful
nowadays
it's really dope for me to watch
actually because it's like very
unmasculine to talk about but it's like
really dope for me to watch
people get up tight and and serious
about like body representation and stuff
like that
because it's something i was trained
you either make fun of yourself or let
people make fun of you right that's kind
of how i was and i was like i could
never be like a romantic person in a
movie and then that seeped into my head
like i can't be a romantic person like
in real life
i'm just there because i'm i'm the only
thing i have to offer is that i'm very
funny
i mean hollywood it's like no new news
flash is vapid and [ __ ]
hello not anymore insane yeah now
they've totally fixed themselves
um
course corrected but like my point being
is that yeah that's the kind of [ __ ] i
was up against when when even when i was
really successful yeah yeah even when i
was successful i just lost the only part
i was interested in the past two years
i was attached to and they re-hired
because i was too good-looking
so now i'm getting i'm getting [ __ ]
over for being in too good of [ __ ] well
that's my problem that's the problem
life that's the uphill battle i faced
the
the the call was that i that i was too
good looking to play the part you're
talking about the rich
richard
but but i've recently met the guy who
got the paul houser who's a phenomenal
actor in person just like you would
really like it but he's the best but he
said about you having seen you in
accepted and and then super bad and he
was like that meant a lot to him as a
younger person as a heavy person he was
like oh that encouraged me to like
seeing you do that and and and
find success was like
super inspiring to him he's now like a
big you know big deal yeah super cool to
think about that i don't think
five years six years ago i'd be able to
even acknowledge this conversation at
all it's crazy because i would what
happened what's the what what chan what
change
you know it's easier to be this
accepting when you are in better shape
yeah okay like it's easier to have this
conversation when you're in that zone i
won't front like yeah of course you know
it's not of course but it is um
but
i wouldn't i wouldn't be happy
ever if i let those rules continue to
apply to me and then i realized i'm
going to work in this business yeah
and maybe not act that much the last
things i did which were like maniac
um
don't worry he won't get far on foot
with walking phoenix
yeah
it's so different too yeah
i've never allowed since i was a kid and
was even tried really hard when i was a
kid to not do it but like
um
[Music]
it's not cool to be the joke if you
don't want to be uh-huh you know what i
mean yeah and that [ __ ] up your
self-esteem i bet so i did a lot of bad
[ __ ] as a person because i was like so
angry yeah so how much of that did so so
that was very deliberate then the not
wanting to address your weight or even
make jokes about it you said there you
go two ways you either like
accept that people make fun of you or
you like make fun of yourself really the
truth is it wasn't i was never good at
accepting that making people making fun
of me so i could be vicious yeah so like
if i saw you heading there
i could eviscerate you and that's one of
the like weaponry of being funny yeah i
was like i'm like had to go into a room
and look at every person and think of
their flaws because if one of them
popped off
i was not allowing that to happen yeah
and you i have to say i mean i've
witnessed that yeah and
i haven't been in years and years and
years really like well i probably
shouldn't say this to encourage it but
as your friend was like a thing to be
honest it was a thing of beauty and i i
i would like to see it comes from pain
yeah yeah you know
it's like it comes and i didn't really
acknowledge no nor would anyone you know
but i mean vince had that too vince was
the same dude you know because he
convinced someone
and but he to me to this day he's the
funniest human being when he's trying to
make you laugh
there's straight up no one in the world
that is funny i would put you in that
group and it's a very small group but
it's it's called it's like
people who who make your face hurt you
know my [ __ ] i feel like a baby like
when vince would would shine his light
on you like to make you laugh and he was
trying to make you laugh there's nothing
i felt like an infant like when they see
like the aquarium thing like above their
crib i was like
you know yeah you're like sheer delight
yeah you like kiss your diaper and like
scream laugh at the like aquarium you
know i think he
liked both of us because we
definitely appreciated him but like
because you were funny and we were funny
he loves justin yeah he's been really
good to me dude he uh remember he like
right away was like justin like that's
my boy what was it like but he
you then you worked with him yeah i
loved it yeah
yeah when all my friends like from
growing up came to visit i mean we grew
up worshiping vince like
i would say like just as a movie nerd
for a second there's never been a debut
like him in swingers where you're like
that is the actual funniest performance
i've ever seen in my life and the guy
looks like paul newman it's crazy you
know like you've never seen like a movie
star where you're like wait this guy
who's like as handsome as paul newman is
like
literally richard pryor like also like
that
like it was like freaking i remember
sitting in the theater with my friend's
older brother who took us and i was like
i was even a little kid like god damn
that guy's handsome yeah like i'm like
eight or something like whatever but you
were like dude this guy is i've never
seen a debut like that in the movie ever
glorious it might be the most like
exceptional debut performance in a movie
evolve but it's not his debut i guess
but like introduction to an audience it
was that it was for me anyway and i but
then when we would hang out he was doing
a lot of like dramas he wanted to be a
more serious so now he's doing like like
like uh how he's doing he works with
that one director that yeah he did bone
tomahawk he just he just like kicks
people's ass
a little bit yeah he's like i'm sorry
what'd you say to me
there's a lot of that but he has that
you know intensity you know so yeah i'm
glad i just hope vince i haven't seen
you a long time but let's hope you're
stoked on what you're doing yeah i hope
your life's good i know i miss him
life could be a dream
[Music]
if you're jewish in my age yeah like
adam sandler and the beastie boys were
like what probably bob dylan and
uh [ __ ] like
you know don rickles were like like like
my dad's generation you know did you get
to meet don rickles
yeah
did he insult you
yes he did make a fat joke but that was
okay
it was like dude you're 90 and you're
literally my favorite comedian of all
time yeah he he goes uh no but he made
fun of himself it was he goes i think we
go to the same gym
it was when i was very overweight and he
was like
a little chubby and he was like
i think i see you if we go to the same
gym
yeah but when i had dinner with him one
time with brad gray rest in peace he's
gone now and uh and uh when wolf of wall
street came out because brad was running
paramount so it was me brad gray
cassandra gray
him his wife who was who is lovely and
leonardo dicaprio oh my god and he went
in on leo what did he say so hard like
the whole dinner it was we there's a
picture of me leo and don rickles that's
like my favorite photographer yeah that
of all time like because he's my
favorite comedian ever of all time hands
down like no one comes close to don
rickles
uh may he rest in a beautiful piece
um and right up into the end he was
sharp and brilliant dude yeah kill yeah
this was like what whatever
yeah well i don't know like 2012 or
something 13.
leo was wearing a news hat like a newsie
kind of boy that's kind of his
look
a cap yeah he's also let me say like
uh
forget what you know or think about him
as an actor and how much he's
accomplished he's one of the top five
human beings i've ever met in my entire
life and has been there as a friend
through thick and thin
and i love this dude so it's kind of
weird because he's so famous that people
are like you refer to him as an actual
human being and they kind of like make a
joke out of it or something yeah and i'm
very sensitive to that because just even
saying leo it's like oh yeah you're like
making fun of me for oh i feel like i
have to make a joke about saying that
but he's my friend and i love him and
like uh human being
besides being brilliant at what he does
is like a brilliant person that's good
to hear he's an intimidatingly good
actor he's one of the few actors i would
be him and joaquin are the two are the
two best yeah you know like that for me
that's like there's no doubt about it
yeah he's so good and like because of
titanic
back in the day wasn't given i think the
credit he deserved if you watch aviator
you're like oh dude he should have won
an oscar for everybody yeah everything
does he and i've heard stories where he
can like these famous stories where he's
like can be in the middle of a video
game pause it then go into the scene is
he not a bit for me that or whatever
like like during wolf of wall street he
would be like dude so where should we
get dinner tonight like blah blah and
then they yell action and then he'd be
like fully jordan belfort that's crying
screaming that's like that's like
savannah yeah that's like touched by god
because my other favorite actor
with joaquin it's like he
convinces himself that it's like
happening
and i'm like that so like if i'm doing a
movie that's more light it's like kind
of fun acting and if i'm doing a movie
that's more dark
it can be really not fun in in a lot of
ways so like but with leo
he's like
he's the best he's like making you laugh
he's telling you like a great story and
then and then the action and he's like
the best actor you've ever seen so those
are my two favorites and what's cool
about
my life i'm very lucky in our job is
like you get to watch all these people
work so like
they're my two favorite actors but their
process is completely different from one
another like there's no shade of the
same process so interesting isn't it so
that's cool dude yeah like that's a cool
thing uh oh really quick these are quick
most commonly used emoji go now because
i started surfing recently it was the
surfer oh emoji
that's sort of like my thumbs up oh
really yeah it's kind of like a friend
because like i as you said i get so like
in the thing like if i start doing
something i do like
20 times a week so like surfing i'm like
a month in and i've gone like probably
30 times you go with charlie mcdowell no
i'm supposed to go with him he was
always offered to teach me in high
school and stuff conway john conway yeah
oh you should oh i'll tell you that
every then you you get into something
you realize everyone does it and they're
great and they'll teach you you know
it's like awesome the first time i do i
went with conway he took me out to like
the bigger he's like trial by fire you
got to go for the big ones and so i the
surfers i met were so [ __ ] nice i
mean it's like that stereotype they're
like what's up bro they were so peaceful
why because they're happy well because
they're doing what they like yeah and
it's hard not to be happy when you're
out in the ocean there but at one point
i i was trying to catch this wave and i
i turned perpendicular to two boards and
i clipped them and they and these were
people who had just been like you were
practicing respect bro exactly and they
got so
[ __ ] hostile with me it's so scary no
it is all like it's all love it's all
love but it's true humility when you go
out there you're like i am new i have to
like declare that i'm new yeah i say
like i suck
and i don't go for [ __ ] unless like i
see that they're not going yeah you know
that's like just picturing you humility
and respect yeah yeah it's funny to
hey i'm just picturing you out there
with them um
if you could be a professional athlete
you may have just answered this what
sport would you play
uh is chess super is this chess a sport
yeah i guess bob i guess no that's their
class but
i'd be honestly i would give everything
up to progress at skateboarding and been
better but i don't even consider that a
sport let's call it i call like
you're not a big sports
voice
but like golf i want to learn i want to
learn golf too
yeah because i think the victory is like
doing it when you're 80. so golf i feel
like you can play
you could be into for the longest period
of time because like basketball you
can't
play when you're older well it's a
similar lesson to what you learned about
the movies and not doing it for reviews
or accolades or whatever uh i it's
probably adjacent to that uh no it's not
no okay
what's your favorite this is gonna be
tough to answer quickly but what's your
favorite movie of all time i always say
the same answer and it's boring and
obvious yeah it's good fellas but
nothing it's amazing nothing comes close
yeah uh if you had to live somewhere
else where would it be
i would live in hawaii be around
beautiful like oceans and stuff like
that um
if you could have dinner with three
people that are alive whom you've never
met
with orange ass warren jasmine
[Laughter]
brian jeffs
samantha jeff honestly dude i may that's
for a perfect example like i would love
to make a movie about warren jeff yeah
right yeah and it's like to bring it
back it's like
what do we really need a movie about
this and it's like but aren't you
interested in how [ __ ] up somebody is
starting jackie or haley or somebody or
yeah you you'd be a great warranty
thank you
sam would be a good word yeah that would
be a good anything at one point when i
did sam was on the podcast he was i was
like who did you like to play he goes
i'd be cool to play elvis and he goes
you could play elvis and i was like sam
i love you but i can't you can play this
okay
okay so if i get dinner with three
people um uh
beat one afternoon with my brother for
sure i would definitely want to have
dinner with um
uh i mean jesus yeah guys like
pretty big deal that's such a funny
invitation for jesus you're his journey
through fame it's probably a lot more
difficult than yours or mine uh he's
ended a little differently i want to
hear who's three people he doesn't want
to have dinner with him and then
honestly oprah dude i like love yeah oh
brilliant speaking of jesus i just like
imagine that dinner would be crazy like
she a few times i've been lucky enough
to me she interviewed me once like
and it's like so i was like 26 or
something i was like like seeing i was
so like oh dude like this is lame like
everyone's thinking i'm corny like blah
blah
and then like i was like i love this
person so after the lunch i was like i
was like i love this person more than
i've ever loved a human being yeah i met
her briefly i it was an embarrassing
moment when drew was on and and she was
like they wanted me in the audience and
i was like i don't want to say anything
and they mic me up and i was like why
are you putting them so i just in case
she talks to you and i was like oh [ __ ]
and i just got out of the shower and
drew was mad i was late and then my hair
was all wet um
and she was like how do you what do you
think of drew
oh it was awful um
uh who who's your favorite muppet
animal ah yeah yeah it's funny people i
really like often say animal uh yeah
yeah a bunch of people he's really
comfortable with himself yes yeah he
just he's just honest he's like an
animal but he doesn't feel like shame
about it animal's problematic now
speaking of things you can't do i just i
really recently animal care yeah i
watched muppet state manhattan recently
and in the beginning they're watching
all the the muppets are watching i think
the movie or they're they're all in a
movie theater an animal this girl runs
out screaming this like large breasted
pretty woman runs out an animal can you
not say that
no really but she did have large bras
can you not say that megan
okay thank you i'm just kidding i don't
i don't follow my sister like call petey
um but if animal runs that she just runs
out screaming and animals like boobies
he goes out like chasing after him oh
he's got he's kind of like got a peppy
lip
a little more like like moose he's a
little horny pedestrian like uh
elementary
yeah pepe lip non-threatening uh yeah
dude animal dude that's not cool yeah no
that's officially not cool i don't know
i don't need petey to tell me yeah i
don't need to make any calls on this one
running down the street screaming
boobies is okay it's crazy it was in a
kid's movie though um if you could have
one two if you get one superpower what
would it be
oh easy i know this i know this it's um
is it called teleportation where i can
snap my fingers and be in like paris or
i could be in like hawaii oh that'd be
amazing dude that's it hands down i'm so
stoked on that yeah yes uh if if you
could be one age for the rest of your
life uh what would you physically what
would you pick
i guess everything i kind of believe in
goes that like i don't want to be one
age for the rest of my life yeah i want
to keep changing that's what that's the
right answer oh there's an official
right yeah oh these are but you were
right on a few of these animals you got
um dogs cats
oh i hate cats yeah i'm really allergic
i'm really allergic to cats beetles
stones
uh both i hate this question okay it's
like why do you like the famous question
is like choose one of the two the two
best man right right well i like both of
them they're great and we've talked
about legacy this is the last question
in terms of um you grew up jewish but
you grew up with a
uh any sort of spiritual life in like a
traditional jewish sense
so do you think about the afterlife do
you think about your own legacy
oh greatest question i think i've had
this discussion recently randomly not
the afterlife part i believe in god and
i believe in the afterlife and i i just
like
i i do believe in god yeah um
i hope there's an afterlife i won't say
i know i don't know [ __ ] so like but i
do believe in god uh the legacy thing i
think is amazing conversation because
legacy oh it was neil brennan you oh
dude that's where i heard it i was like
i said i had this conversation but it
was listening to your podcast that's so
cool it was what neil and you were
saying about legacy i thought was like
the most genius thing ever and now he's
like drops like dude he's so [ __ ]
smart and funny yeah and but really so
smart yeah um i keep saying yeah he's a
genius i keep quoting him and thinking
about things that he said dude his
podcast was the champs was my like my
him in motion cash it was like my
favorite podcast oh he's got a new one
called which is the best title of any
podcast it's called how neil feel
it's so good
yeah yeah
that's really good subscribe to that
[ __ ]
um
but like uh like
uh what's it called the uh but legacy
about about legacy oh i was literally
about to repeat what
you guys said on your podcast which is
like it's officially the dumbest thing
ever yeah
it's officially if you had to like say
what is the dumbest thing ever it's
thinking about what people are gonna
think of you when you're dead right
right well were we talking about like
movie stars from like the 20s and 30s
through like
jane
to lulu like people that now you'd be
like hoop it at the time i think about
that when i walk down because i've been
walking to the gym down hollywood
boulevard and all the the stars you know
like first of all there are homeless
people everywhere and it's the craziest
juxtaposition to see like these stains
of like
humans suffering and
next to like a star and next to like you
know
it's like star uh i think i think i mean
clearly i think that [ __ ] doesn't matter
i hope that's very clear about this
interview yeah um
where would you want your star to be i'm
just kidding
um outside of fatburger i really like
fat burger um who i care about what they
think about me when i die or the people
that were in my immediate life yeah if
you didn't spend a significant amount of
time with me i don't give a [ __ ] what
you think about it yeah
that's brand new for me dude because i
was gonna say i was like doctor cares
about who what everyone thinks
professor cares what everyone thinks
like that was my middle name that's like
the most unhealthy [ __ ] in the world
yeah well i'm so glad you dude i got to
go to jiu-jitsu good good you guys can
be here with my house in islam no no
okay i love you i thank you you have to
do this i'm so glad you did of course i
had to do this like
i will say
i've said it to you personally say it to
you publicly
i would not be um
the kind of friend i can now be because
of you but also
you literally
were
gave me a place to stay helped with my
career
i would not be let's say where i'm at is
a bad terminology because it doesn't
matter where i'm at in my career because
it doesn't exist but like
you helped me a lot in my life and i
love you and i care about you it's a
point of pride for me and yeah i think
it worked out the only thing i'm pissed
to you about is that jim our old
landlord wasn't physically how did you
not physically get him for the podcast
[Music]
[Laughter]
so
that's what we used to say about jonah
that he was like a bro i never heard
that combination of like a jewish kid
who like sounded like a little bit like
a surfer in california and that just
happened yeah he uh that just happened a
little bit like bill from build a little
keanu
no it's a little bit like that yeah well
that happened
how would you say it uh well well it
definitely happened yeah yeah it 100
percent happen oh no i know i was there
oh yeah i i could have told you that
before you heard it uh it happened it
was you know it's funny i
uh of all these interviews i think
i mean definitely not i think i
definitely know
him the best out of like way more than
the other guests so it was kind of hard
for me to to be objective about
the interview itself you know what i
mean it's it's hard to like analyze a
lot of it just felt
in a really good way i think kind of
like a couple's therapy like like you
know friends couples therapy you know we
both have
talk i've talked about this before like
the uh struggles with jealousy and like
back in the day like being having a
different value system now and i
definitely went through that there was
there was a moment with jonah that i of
course when he started to like really
blow up and we both had
issues with one another that
over the years we've since addressed and
in this way just talking to him here it
was nice to see that they there weren't
any lingering remnants of that but
jonah did you know when he started
blowing up he he did things to me that i
know he regrets i know he regrets and
has made amends for and i had feelings
toward him that i regret feeling because
um starting to sound very romantic
[Laughter]
well you know like friendships go
through we were such good friends that
of course
both going through such major changes
especially jonah that um
and stuff like that is bound to happen
and i hate to be cryptic about it but i
am only because like it's it's the stuff
itself was not important it's important
between us but we dealt with it and like
have made moved on i also think it's a
lot of people will be able to relate to
that you know
when you've been friends with someone
for 15
plus years right it's natural to have
that ebb and flow and [ __ ] comes up and
people get pissed and but then you make
up but i think the key thing is
getting over it getting back and getting
back to where you are and that's that's
when you know you have a friend like a
friend that will stand the test of time
because even the best of friends will go
through [ __ ] and that's really
comforting to me because all that other
stuff that gets in the way and i think
we've both dealt with that in really
healthy ways and and he's clearly done a
lot of work on himself i think you know
that's evident to go from just a kid
like a random kid
uh growing up in la to
living in your pantry yeah and like he
says and nine months later he's on
billboards it's it's uh it must it must
be really difficult i mean again you
don't be like boo hoo like no bad for
just psychologically it must be
extremely difficult to
wade through some of those waters yeah
that's why beanie really is lucky that
she has
i mean jonah talks a lot about how
grateful he is to beanie but beanie is
too because she had jonah kind of like
went through all the bad stuff too and
you know i remember when we were friends
we
formed a really quick friendship and i
remember his
high school friends later saying who who
jonah in this this will be a testament
to his like loyalty he's still friends
with his high school friends
i met jonah we were hanging out a lot i
didn't see much of those high school
friends and then
this following summer then he got into
the judd apatow crew and i didn't see
much of him and i remember thinking like
oh you know i miss my friend he's now
and i remember talking at that time to
his high school friend schmidt and luke
and they were like yeah that's how we
felt about you that we felt like you had
replaced us you know and
and then those abatto guys maybe felt
like they got replaced so he kept
climbing the sliders
dicaprio yeah and then like now he's
hanging out the dalai lama yeah yeah he
was left
pope francis is like oh man
we were buddies
but um all of that is he's gone on such
a journey and and a testament to his
like character that he is uh able to
recognize the mistakes he made and um
and he's a better person for it it's
funny he he refers to himself as uh a
dorky guy he's like i was just a dorky
guy who like a b and c happened to me i
never saw him as a doctor i never and
and he he may have felt that way he may
have felt and i know he admits to
feeling insecure about certain things
but
from the night i met him i never would
have described him as a dorky guy only
because
anyone who would like i said hold court
around these
confident yeah impressive like
accomplished people and a lot of alphas
yeah that's not to me that's not what a
dorky guy but again
i'm i believe him when he says he felt
like that
but objectively i don't think anyone
would have described him as a dorky guy
no but it's interesting he's just so
self-assured yeah he's two he's way too
self-assured for me to ever describe
mess a torchy guy that's right because i
believe him when he says he feels like
confidence he really pulled off not
showing it you know what i mean yeah a
great acting job yeah i didn't know this
that he
did cyrus instead of the hangover turn
on the hangover i didn't know that
either which again not a dorky guy move
to
turn down that dorks would have done the
hangover i mean would in retrospect is
has become this you know monster comedy
franchise i remember when he turned down
transformers too you guys talked about
that and i remember thinking we both
all of us were like what did he do what
is he doing why would he turn that down
it's like the third lead in a massive
movie and in order to become as
successful as he is i think it requires
just this confluence of things it
requires talent obviously right
intelligence good sense of humor
courage to go for it yeah but also like
it requires a really shrewd sense of
decision-making totally you know but he
really fought hard not to be typecast
which is
smart but it's it's really
courageous of him being an overweight
guy and saying
you know what i'm not gonna just like
play the fat guy no again not a dorky
move not a dorky move yeah it's like a
really cool movie yeah god confident
cool
i wish i got into his tattoos speaking
of cool so many more now i mean he i
remember when he forgot that first one i
remember thinking that is weird he his
first one was nanny rules
and it was for his grandma and it was
around a heart it's it was like a
perfect tattoo for jonah because it was
like
funny it was sweet it was like
acknowledging he's very close with his
family he was acknowledging like
somebody he loved in his family but it
was also it had everything and now i see
these like
designs and eagles and maybe not eagles
i'm trying to remember what there were
so many pigeons mostly at sparrows
i i want to get into them but didn't
have time
uh i laughed out loud when he said when
you guys were talking about zendaya and
he said he was the zendaya at this time
and i pictured him in one of those
billboards with the tear running down
his face
zendaya so funny oh my god
um
he told that story about when he was in
the car on the way to that premiere for
his movie and he was obsessively
checking yeah the rotten tomatoes score
and not only is it impressive that he
admitted that because it's not it's not
flattering it's not flattering but
the lesson in there is
super important because
even you know obsessing over this
podcast or relationships or for anybody
like how is it doing or what do people
think of it or like instagram like check
get enough videos exactly
the validation validation i mean the
lesson obviously being that the thing
itself and in this case the movie he
worked so hard at making with his
friends and
that is the thing
that's the experience that's the thing
that he should
uh care about it's a really i mean it's
like a basic lesson but it's
a really important lesson a lesson that
i
need to remind myself of constantly and
i think other people me too
i can see how that was a big wake-up
call to for him and how it must have
changed or like redirected his behavior
drastically yeah i think i'm just like
glad that happened to him yeah uh
mid-90s when he said mid-90s is the
christie yamaguchi story really made me
laugh
there were glimpses of like oh
man just like being funny and like chit
chat like we used to we always used to
go to this bar renee's and just like
laugh and like people watch and like
make each other like and there were
glimpses of that that was so fun him
doing his impression of dave matthews
band made me laugh so hard too he's like
it reminded me of do you remember when i
heard him uh he was in his bedroom
oh have you co-opted the story totally
oh no this happened to me this is a
perfect example we were talking about i
was in the kitchen and i heard you know
that song it's going down yep
[Music]
sugar you're going down swinging
number one with the bullet
gun complex
so i heard him
like loudly singing that song in his
room and i was like making something in
the kitchen
and i will never forget how
like into it he was and he ended the
song by going
and he said it so he's saying it so like
precisely
and like as he finished the song he he
opened the door and saw that i was there
and he was like so embarrassed and he
was like were you there the whole time
but it reminded him doing that dave
matthews band impression reminded me of
that so i
to this day this hap that you caught him
so funny i love that man i just love
this story so much i in my head i was
like i saw him do that i could but
you're right i i don't have a clear
memory of that but i always we always
say that to each other now like don't
pull it
and pull it but we always say it's
always in the context of like hey should
we go out and should we get a you know
meet up for a drink or something and he
you know just like he'll punctuate those
texts with like cockatoo bullets let's
go like let's do it
it was very nostalgic hearing you guys
talk about that house on wadsworth
that was so fun and even now i'm like
flooded with all these memories that
like oh it'd be fun to talk about like
one of the i think the only physical
fight i got into with a guy was with
jonah that's right um and we and me
jonah and james duffy who's hopefully
listening uh the three of us took on one
guy
and then it was like a tie
you all get separated well and then he
put me in a headlock we had on the
ground but his other hand we were on we
ended up on i ended up on the ground
with him because he swung at jonah jonah
sorry long story but anyway i ended up
on the ground with a guy and i just
remember being not this makes me sound
like tough but his only because his one
arm was put had me in a headlock is the
other arm he was on he was like he'd
fallen on so he couldn't get it out of
him from underneath him and the two of
us it was so funny because it was
obviously like very violent and hostile
situation but our faces were like kind
of like our heads were like mashed
together kind of so our faces it was
really intimate we were like
we could have like easily kissed each
other
our faces were next to each other and
and i was like look this is stupid what
are we doing we're going to get kicked
out this is i'm trying to like rational
i'm like nervously like rationalizing
with him and he's like you [ __ ]
i'm gonna [ __ ] kick you and he was
being a dick this guy and as it turns
out um so then we both got pulled up by
bouncers both got kicked out as it turns
out the guy had been 86 from this from
this uh
from this kid's party
yeah now i'm from this bar called
renee's he had he had gotten kicked out
of chuck e cheese's you ran out of his
detention when he's in eighth grade
um i like his take on people pleasers
like you um and he you know he talks
about not having enough gas in the tank
for your loved one so you need to
reserve enough of yourself enough energy
for people
who
actually care about you yeah you know
who
really know you and really care about
you and not so you can't spread yourself
too thin which
i think you sometimes spread yourself
yeah i mean you're good at obviously
maintaining room for your loved ones but
no but that's important but it's
important to keep keep that in mind i
think well that relates to the reviews
too and critics people on the internet
people who don't know you like saying
[ __ ]
i loved the warren jeff's through line
throughout the interview and i
hope you're not insulted by this but i
think you would
make a pretty good war on jeff's if
there was oh my god there's a movie
about him oh my god there's something
sort of like
similar body wise about you guys
that is you know what that actually like
oh man that that makes me all my
paranoia is about like my looks like
he's not an unattractive guy
he's shaped like a skeksi from the dark
crystal he is a sexy body he's like a
bird man he's shaped like a like a lazy
bird
but but you know what you're right i
know what you're saying you've just
confirmed all of my fears about my
physical
about my looks
god because i don't have great posture
sometimes i catch myself i'm like i look
like a nerdy vulture the way i'm
standing i'm like
hunched okay you're somewhere in between
he has no chin you're somewhere in
between warren jeffs and james
you fall somewhere i'll take that at all
okay
closer to warren jeff's okay
um but that was really fun that was that
was really uh jonah i wish i'd been
there it was right i know we he
i was really fun to listen to he he
wishes you're very nostalgic i know but
didn't it bring back some yeah fun
memories yeah it was really fun uh so
thanks to our our pal joan i just we
love him and and uh i hope you guys
enjoyed listening to that um and we now
hope you enjoy listening to this we're
gonna read another letter
as we do uh and again if you
want to write in yourself the email
address you can write into is life is
short at wondery.com so if you have a
letter if you want to write anything you
want really but um the our goal is to
uh to get people to write in and say
what
they like how they find
value in life and what they certain
specific things they do to find uh
meaning in life in their in their own
lives how they [ __ ] it and pull it [ __ ]
it and pull it going down down we should
have the follow up i'll fall out man
they're fallout men now but yeah
um okay this is from kelly w hi
my name is kelly and today i texted my
brother
quote because life is short so i figured
i'd send you the context
um i've been involved with music since i
was little taking piano and guitar
lessons in elementary school and singing
in choir for over a decade i'm using
some of my music skills at work for an
event my manager is running and she
asked me if i play the fiddle
i said no but i've always wanted to
learn a string instrument ah me too
kelly ah i mean yeah
i played the violin when i was a kid but
i'm testing it but cool yeah
during lunch i went to a local music
store bought a fiddle like she was
referring to it as a fiddle and now i
have two months to learn it my manager
was definitely half joking when she
asked me but i figured now is a good
time as any
to pick up a new hobby she awakened a
little music monster in me and the
monster is ready to learn how do you
half joke about asking someone if they
play the fiddle i know it's either a
full joke or it's or another joke right
true or is it serious question do you
play do you play the fiddle i'm i'm i'm
[ __ ] with you that's a joke yeah it's
a weird joke
anyway sorry's interesting doesn't the
devil play a fiddle in a lot of like
lore isn't i'm always seeing like a
little devilish person because she says
she waking the little music monster me
now i'm picturing like a little like
cloven-hoofed
demon playing a fiddle am i why oh is it
dang devil and daniel webster is he
playing
oh no no the devil went to devil went
down to georgia he was looking for a
soul
yeah it was okay save it for that guy's
podcast
moving on okay so i told my brother this
is back to kelly i took kelly didn't do
a charlie daniels aggression
so i own a fiddle now and i'm gonna
learn it because life is short that's
cool that is cool trying a new thing
i feel i feel like trying a new thing
and by trying to learn an instrument or
learning a language i feel like that
automatically is going to make your life
better just the pursuit of doing
something totally you know just doing it
just having that in your back pocket
being having that it makes you richer
makes traveling easier i've been trying
to learn
my language my spanish is so limited
that every year i get inspired to learn
it again and and um i don't so i hope
thanks for your motivation kelly and
thanks for writing in and thank you guys
for listening
to life is short and thanks uh to the
great jonah hill
our old uh housemate your old roommate
yeah it was really fun
[Music]
thank you guys for listening uh to life
is short if you enjoyed the show
maybe give it a five star review i feel
weird asking no pressure no problem no
pressure no pressure you don't have to
we're available on apple podcast spotify
google podcast and every major listening
app as well as wondering.com life is
shortest hosting hosted hosting
by me
justin liang it's produced by christian
long and megan monaco michelle lanz mish
is our senior producer our engineer is
marcelino villapando executive produced
by marshall louie and hernan lopez for
wondering our theme song is performed by
our other very good friend karmar
superstar
[Music]
[Music]
that well like you're that hat
yeah but you do to your own head with
chia
exactly
how would i do it it grows and it grows
how would i do that it's impossible
i'm saying hypothetically okay i'm
saying if this was a possible thing okay
would i make myself a chia head yeah
would you make yourself a chia head with
that like substance in that loop
um
for one year of your life wow
for
two million dollars
and you can never wear a hat
can it be a year that i'm with a woman
who likes me no it starts tomorrow who
can't wear a hat no
holy [ __ ] two million dollars two
million dollars tax-free
um
no it's tax
it's like um think of it like it's a uh
estate tax
[Music]
that's hard
trying to imagine what like
realistically like why take the tax i
was just complicating that prophetical
let's say
tax-free one million dollars okay one
million
i don't it's so funny to try to picture
your face with that ladies
i'm also imagining going to sleep and
then coming off so easily oh i think
it'd be comfortable it would be like no
no
wouldn't they fall off easily they're
little tiny petals
are you picturing me with them falling
like mashed
it'd be ludicrous are you gonna wear a
hat never mind i would need like ten
i need a lot i need a lot of money
are you matching up putting me viewing
an actual chat i'm picturing you
dealing with that yeah and having little
pieces fall off and they'd be so broken
it'd be so funny
[Laughter]
i do it for a month i do it for a month
that's not on the table
how much would a month be that'd be
funny
but you could always just like kind of
take a year off and stay inside and like
write like for
a year it'd be so depressing
not the whole year you'd go out like
once a week but then i'd be like the
chia head freak
that'd be tough that'd be tough oh my
god no girls forget girls
unless you were like a hipster novelty
exactly you might get girls that's true
and by the way in the same temple you
couldn't explain that it's like a dairy
you were doing you didn't i'm saying
that's my hair it's true like dennis
robin has like crazy green afros so it's
their plants
you